remind me a text Cory something really
rude Kanye was like I think it's weird
like we've never met his family that's
weird the Kardashians have a bone to
pick with mama kris Jenner's bull of
four years
Cory gamble mainly who the heck are ya
Cory does tend to be pretty secretive so
me and all of the kids we just we've
been more on guard with Cory
naturally this didn't sit well with
Chris it's rude I would never disrespect
somebody easily that I have his opinions
we are you know show those
vulnerabilities and we're also
transparent everybody thinks they know
the whole story and they don't later in
the episode Kim and Chloe felt bad for
questioning Cory so they all met up to
have a candid conversation me Kourtney
Khloe and Rob saw my dad go through like
different relationships the second they
got married flipped and we literally
would give them such how to where they
would bring up with my dad because the
four of us were like monsters we just
want to say we're sorry if we've ever
been distant whatever and it's not an
excuse but from our past that those are
the reasons why we wanted to share that
with you
Cory keV did real explaining why he's
chosen to keep his personal matters
private my best friend / the lady that
raised me died in November you know that
was a big loss because I really have
felt like I've had nobody since dad but
honey brings people round yeah I just
they're in the middle for the peace
trying the rest of the season has so
many crazy things going on and as I say
every time you guys ask it's just two
men because you never know what's gonna
happen
lots of exciting moments for the
Kardashian crew this year especially for
Kim and Kanye not only did they welcome
their fourth child together a son named
Psalm if the inspiration was the Book of
Psalms in the Bible so I think it's just
a wonderful way to celebrate you know
how they feel
he's such a blessing so it's perfect
he's just adorable
they also celebrated their five-year
wedding anniversary in the most regal
way possible a surprise trip to Vegas to
see Queen Celine Dion
[Music]